what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have my little sister on the
channel say hi
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
just so you guys know we are reacting to
the fresh and fit podcast
amelia has never seen it's not looking
like i'm torturing you
amelia has never seen fresh and fit
before
so this one is titled myron almost
popped a blood vessel again so we're
just gonna see
what it's about you ready
a little worried
this podcast is much more and here's
they're kind of um they're kind of
players a little bit i think so you guys
got to understand bro we all know that
women
oh my body count is uh 25.
stop the cat bro no like yeah
seriously oh no i picked the wrong super
like bro
super cat no way like no way bro there's
no way you got 25 body count
like no because here's the thing bro let
me give you guys a little uh
in depth of what body count is how many
people are you slept with
view of the female mindset okay that's
how women think all right
they only count the bodies of dudes that
they like remember and like had fun with
okay that does not count the one-night
stands that does not count the dudes
that they met
at the foam cannon in cancun shout out
to our boy rolo and the guys in tulum
that they smashed
you know uh uh i didn't what does your
youtube
feed look like on a daily basis it
literally looks like this stuff
it's like men's dating advice
you are so single
someone had to say it
oh i forgot what
i'm surprised what do you mean
you forgot what i forgot that you and
one year were together
yeah one hitter i expected you to be
single for a lot longer
oh my gosh okay we're just gonna we're
gonna continue that
twitter in the bathroom stall at a club
bro they don't count any of that
i know girls that don't count it if it's
a condom on
yeah i mean yo bro what
women use all kinds of mental gymnastics
to rationalize their poor behavior
because here's the thing bro do you
think
it matters
i mean it depends what do you mean
because if you're
let's say you're like 17 you say you
have a higher body count than most
adults do then that's a little weird
but if you're an adult that's not really
my problem
oh it's not so do you think guys should
only date girls that haven't slept with
a lot of people
if you like retellings it's their
opinion but
i don't know
you don't have like an opinion not
really
not really a guy so 1000 facts notice
how she said
the male eagles but they're from miami
so miami
that's what i'm saying miami's like
there's a lot of hoes in miami
yeah it's a very different lifestyle i
know
so that's why i drive because you don't
want to know that i hang out with
certain types of guys blah blah blah
blah blah
again what do i always tell you guys on
this podcast
anything that represses female sexuality
is always going to be met with some kind
of contempt and shaming language
small dick energy insecure you're you're
just jealous uh you're not you're an
[ __ ] you're misogynistic whatever
blah blah [ __ ] blah
how dare you but i'll tell you guys this
like i said before
why the hell are you gonna pay full
price for a goddamn car that's been used
what women don't understand is men don't
ask for much okay
if i'm gonna take you seriously as a
girlfriend and or a wife
my only real request is that you don't
embarrass me and [ __ ] other guys
okay but they have the [ __ ] gall to
sit here
and say yeah it's a care yeah it's a
cure no you dumb [ __ ]
i'm not [ __ ] insecure i'm very secure
in my goddamn confidence
i don't want to [ __ ] wipe up no hoe
all right and i'm tired of women out
here
telling dudes smells like enemy small
dick
[ __ ] i'm not going to the lamborghini
dealership with 300 bands to pay 200
thousand
three for [ __ ] pay 300 000 for a
lambo with 200 000 miles on it bro
it's [ __ ] we need to start holding
these women accountable you want to
what do you think
he's very angry no i know
but it's like a fake anger almost like i
don't know how to describe it
but you ever like hear those guys that
like
want to be super like macho but they're
naturally not
that's what i think of when i hear him
there
do you think what he's saying is right
or wrong i can barely understand ninety
percent of what he's saying because he's
just yelling it
dude that six feet twelve hundred
thousand dollars a year gonna protect
you in times of danger
take care of you be a leader six figure
[ __ ] abs all this extra [ __ ] but you
can't even be
a [ __ ] decent woman and not be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here bro
i need you guys to hold these women
accountable too they gotta meet
your metrics because i'm tired of girls
having preferences and saying this is
what i want this is my profile you think
girls have too high of standards
a lot of them do yes do you think some
girls think they're prettier than they
are
i didn't say anything um
do you think some girls i find it funny
when gabrielle makes tick tocks about
guys being like
what like five eight and then she's
acting like she's
towering over them when i'm five nine
i'd only be an inch taller than these
people yeah
so like and gabriel's like oh my god
you're so tall like
you were saying oh the that they're
short
yeah so do you think um
so do you think that most girls have too
high of standards
a lot of them do yeah yeah because
that's that's what okay so this is what
the whole nanosphere started from
was because basically um the top 20
of guys are sleeping with 80 of the
women
so girls that are like a five like
average looking
are demanding like a guy with six pack
abs
yeah you know what i'm saying so like
all these guys that are being passed
over
by these women that are just like
sleeping with these guys does that make
sense like the guys like don't want to
date them they just want to sleep with
them
and so these girls like think they're on
their level
are you too young for this conversation
no okay
um okay so do you think there's a
difference between
like a guy that wants to sleep with you
and a guy that wants to date you
probably
okay yeah be careful she's young
this is what i like in men and then if i
turn around and say well okay i don't
want some hope oh my god
how dare you [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm tired of
men
having standards and then women sitting
there and saying that's discrimination
[ __ ] you it's not discrimination it's
reality okay
we don't want hoes okay
you want to be a hoe that's fine but you
got to lay in your [ __ ] bed
and sleep there just like lana rhodes
just like mia khalifa just like all
these other girls
do you know who they are i know who mia
khalifa is
[ __ ] on camera and think let me get a
guy to pay full price for this used
[ __ ] car
it never works it never works because
i always say this reality does not
adhere
to social constructs again say that one
more time
these dumb bimbos out there
[Music]
[Applause]
reality does not conform to your social
constructs
in other words most guys in reality
are not going to accept you for being a
hoe and put a ring on it it's always
going to [ __ ] bother them okay
so if you want to be a hoe okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna stop him right there
this is where i think he's wrong
most girls even mia khalifa could have
she found a guy to marry her
now did she divorce him later yes
but like most girls can find someone i'm
not even gonna lie to you
literally like the girl from precious
found someone
that was making six figures that's what
i think the man of sphere gets wrong
it's fine that's your personal decision
but be ready for the [ __ ]
consequences of not dude's not taking
you serious you want to have a hot girl
summer
all right [ __ ] you're gonna have a
bunch of hot girl summers buy
self you make your bed lay in it all
right
[ __ ] out of here man tired of these
chicks
[Music]
cause it's [ __ ] that men can't have
standards it's [ __ ] we don't ask do
you think that's true
yeah like if a guy says i don't want to
date a girl that slept with a lot of
people
people say it's insecure yeah do you
think that's fair
or no yeah you think it is fair for him
to say that
yeah i think um
do you think that like men are called
like women haters when they say that
sometimes yeah and you do you think
that's wrong
it can be depending on like the context
of it
like what what kind of context like
i don't know how to explain it also lazy
the way like i think of it is like i
hate it when guys go out of their way
to make girls like feel bad you know
but i don't i think like people can date
who they want to date
you know okay
guys i swear i did not make her do this
video she
said she was bored we really don't girls
ask all for these things and then you
say all right well i just don't want you
to be a whole oh my god
you [ __ ] small dick energy you're
insecure
[ __ ] out of here man if i'm gonna invest
into you i need to know
you are not used man super saiyan for
damn god damn that was fire bro in miami
good luck
so i'm telling y'all all 5 400 you guys
you meet a girl
put her through her [ __ ] paces okay
she's gotta work
for your affection not all the way
around a lot of you guys oh baby please
be my girlfriend oh i know you're a hoe
and i know you'll be doing all this
extra [ __ ] on the side but please be my
girlfriend
[ __ ] that she needs to be coming to you
please be my boyfriend i know i'm a haw
and everything like that but please
please please i need that security and
then you can tell her oh well you know
what you got to show me all the other 10
girls
maybe i'll take you serious that's how
you got to do it and she's going to
respect you
because now you're holding her ass to a
standard for once in her [ __ ] life
she's being held to a standard i'm
telling ya he's attractive
do you think that girls aren't held to
high standards
it i mean it depends
some of them are some of them just
aren't what do you mean like by it
depends
like who who is because a lot of the
like girls who are on like the bigger
end are always
judged more because they're just like
not skinny even though a lot of guys
want skinny girls
which i feel like that's stupid because
that's just like their body type and
they can't really control that most of
the time
you can control sometimes you can't
sometimes you're just born on the bigger
end
no you're not yes you are but honey have
you ever looked at pictures from the
1950s
40s no 30s i don't care about the time
no but i'm saying like it was the same
genetics
like people haven't mutated and changed
from that time
and like that none of those girls were
overweight
so like the only thing that changed is
the food
i'm sure the people who were overweight
weren't taking pictures
yeah they would be like do you think
they just
how else would they avoid like
why would they only take pictures of
skinny people it would just be like if
you looked at a picture of people
walking
like even in our family like the people
that are bigger you can tell they eat
more
right yeah you're skinny but you don't
eat that much you've never eat that much
no you don't you don't see how many
times i get out of my room during the
night to grab snacks no i
i see you like when we eat dinners it's
cause i don't know really and i
i struggle with my weight i'm bigger
than you i'm not i'm not fat
but like but it's because i eat more i
just say like five cupcakes today
you're welcome they're so good she made
them guys
okay the frosting wasn't that good but
back to what we were saying i think
though that big girls like
they're told they're beautiful all the
time there's like this body positivity
movement
but men don't have that
true so like that's why and usually like
girls won't date the fat guy but guys
will date the fat girl
yeah that happens more times than not
girls they go through their entire
existence
with a man never telling them no okay i
need you [ __ ] to start saying
no more
you know the scary part man fatality if
you
actually wait for one of these girls bro
you take it seriously
she can't have a pair bond so what
happens is you wipe her up you take her
in
and she's hella hella miles on her body
you know what i'm saying
and at that point what do you get a used
beat up product
that can't even work properly she can't
pair a bond so it's gonna it's gonna
break up anyway
and the worst scenario is it should
marry her you know what hair bonding is
no so um when you sleep with someone you
release oxytocin
does that make sense okay that's like
it's like a chemical that makes you bond
with someone
so the more people that you sleep with
like
um your ability to bond with them
decreases so you're not able to bond as
much like it's like
almost like an ability that you lose the
more people you sleep with
and that's why um like naturally
men don't like girls that sleep around
because like if a girl has
sex with more people they tend to like
leave their husbands because they're not
as bonded to them
he's staring into my soul oh my god
but um that's why it's really important
to like
be careful with that stuff like because
there's always like the religious
argument which i don't really like but i
think if people talked more about like
the science behind it it would make more
sense to a lot of people
that's divorce right there and then so
myron's right man like
you don't want to buy a used car with
high mileage [ __ ] [ __ ] bro you
don't
like no one bats an eye when a woman
says i don't want no broke [ __ ] i don't
want no loser i don't want no shortcut i
don't want no fat boys
we're never gonna knock women for their
preferences all i'm saying is that
men need to be able to have their
preferences and act on it without being
attacked
yeah it's bs bro it's bs you know what
i'm saying
y'all wanna walk down the aisle in a
white dress and get married but none of
you guys want to be [ __ ] wise you
want to keep your instagram open you
want to be able to keep your male
friends you want to still have your
girls nights out you still want to be
able to do all this extra stuff
while still getting the security from a
man women want traditional men
without being traditional women all i'm
telling you guys is you guys need to
[ __ ] wake
up that's why this podcast exists okay
we're waking men up everything this is
the only thing
is they act like they're the ultimate
bearers of truth and they have all the
answers
and i'm like not really that's that's
why i hate that
but what do you think so far any other
thoughts
not really every [ __ ] day we're the
alarm clock to this [ __ ]
you guys need to put women's feet to the
fire
and make them work for you because you
have to bring
way more to the table than they [ __ ]
do yeah last time i checked
hypergamy is a thing and what does that
mean they date up
okay since they date up that means that
you're dating down
and since you're dating down that [ __ ]
better start sucking some dick
[ __ ] making you food all this extra
[ __ ] do you know how pergamy is
no so it basically means that girls
tend to date up in terms of like looks
and
um money
so if a girl makes fifty thousand
dollars she wants a guy that's makes
more than fifty thousand
if a girl is a five she wants a guy
that's a six
does that make sense yeah you guys are
so
willing to date and take women seriously
that don't do [ __ ] for you bro
besides have some ass and some blood
fillers here's the worst part
you take her in she can do [ __ ] for you
i guarantee you
she's gonna do [ __ ] for somebody else
and it ain't you so
who's losing here you're losing so real
talk guys like martin said earlier
if you're gonna get a chick in your life
have some standards have some boundaries
and at least
at least require to one time
i'll say this man most you guys out here
right now right you're dating girls
right now
and they're walking all over you you're
paying the bills you're taking care of
maybe her kids whatever
you're the one going to paces what are
they doing oh babe i want to go here
i want to do this i won't do that you do
it all the time
and you're scared losing her but guess
what bro she's scared of losing you
so real talk when it comes to respect
and everything like that
despite yourself bro because guess what
they don't respect you
see you can tell they're kind of jaded
okay what do you think interesting
which who did you like better kevin
samuels or fashion bet
which one was which uh fresh and fit was
the second one
the first guy was very loud
the the black guy or the oh
they were both black wait um
oh you mean the two different i meant
the two different people in the video
oh no i meant like the first video we
watched so kevin samuels or the second
one's fresh and fit like one guy's fresh
one's
fit oh in the second video that one guy
was really loud
yeah i'm not of the biggest i prefer
kevin samuel's depression but
i prefer minecraft youtubers
okay guys but let me know in the
comments who you guys prefer um let me
know what videos i should show
my little sister next she's 14
so she's still my baby sister um
oh yeah we can take these out but don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell and i will
talk to you guys
next time